okay some people think my music is
dope some people see me as like this
satanic
devil but
[Music]
me when I was a kid my sexuality was
just like the elephant in the room I
started getting bad like anxiety attacks
all coming out was very important to
progress just put out Channel I'm hit
y'all back a year from
now we going to see where I'm at my mind
is hardwire since a kid when you up
you have to quit the whole thing I feel
like there's something Brewing that's
going to be so amazing I trust that
feeling
baby I'm not like able to be 100% around
like family
[Music]
members I feel like there's a lot of
things that people may want to say but
don't I'm always just trying to
challenge the way my family like looks
at things I'm going to teach my nephews
to not be homophobic hey hey y'all don't
don't be
homophobic
okay so many queer people are making
these huge strides but it's a
fight hello family it's like crazy to
walk out in front of like both sides of
your family in like this little skirt
what's up
[Music]
Dad there's still parts of myself that I
am learning to
accept but we getting
[Music]
closer